I've been working with the cast of Little House on the Prairie
for a little over a year and I have been working primarily with Dean Butler
best known as Almanzo/Almonzo Wilder
on Little House of the Prairie
he marries Laura
this is me and Dean last week at Silver Dollar City
I run all of his social accounts
so I've been doing that for the last year
and if you don't follow him here on TikTok
he's almost at 100,000 which was our goal for this year
he's almost at 100,000 and we started him last year with absolutely no followers
I'm very very excited for him
and then he also has Instagram and Facebook
and I've been running all of that for the last year
and then here's Linwood Boomer
who played Adam Kendall and Dean with myself
this was in March of this year
they had a massive 50th anniversary festival in Simi Valley
California that was literally a dream come true
let me show you who else I got to meet is one of my all time favourite photos
this is me and Karen Grassley
who played mall we wore the same cardigan that day
and she had thought cause she didn't have her cardigan on
she thought that I had taken her cardigan out of her bag and was like
halfway through the date darling
she's darling I'm gonna need that back
and I was like Karen
this is mine and she was like
and she opened her bag we put on the cardigan
posed for this photo I mean iconic
this is me with the sweet Landon children
this is Leslie Landon Michael Landon's daughter
and Michael Landon junior
he's also the director of when calls the heart
and he's the creator of all of that
and so so fun talking to them about their dad
Leslie and I have stayed in touch
and we talk monthly um
adore her love her
they're incredible
and talking to them about their dad just makes me so emotional
this is me in front of the set of The Little House
they recreated the sets for The Little House
the Mercantile and the church
and it was just incredible oh
going into 2025
there is so many things happening with the cast of Little House on the Prairie
and I'm gonna be involved in helping facilitate events going forward
and I'm so excited for the cast and so excited for the fans of Little House
and this is literally a dream come true for me
I grew up watching Little House on the Prairie with my grandparents
and my grandparents's names for Charles and Carolyn
so it was literally perfect
and being involved with such an iconic show is a dream come true
that I never could have imagined this for myself
but yes
I've been doing this for the last year
next year I will be full
full time Little House
like everything everything in my life will be Little House next year
and I'm just so grateful for the opportunity
let me show you one more picture
this is my sister and I with the cast of Little House
this picture was taken in March at the big Simi Valley event
and as you can see this is iconic
literally these people are some of my closest friends
and now knowing them on a personal level
like they're incredible human beings
and it is a joy and an honour to work alongside them
and we just have the best time